for the election of the Member of
Parliament for the Halton constituency
held on the 8th June 2017
hi the undersigned being the acting
returning officer at the election of a
member of parliament for the Halton
constituency give notice that the number
of votes recorded for each candidate at
the election is as follows
Beit Ryan Stephen Robert Liberal
Democrats 896 Lloyd Matthew the
conservative and unionist party 10710
Riddick n' Glynn UK Independence Party
1488 Turton Vic independent 309 twig
Derek Labour Party 36,000 150
the number of ballot papers rejected
we're as follows for want of an official
mark none for voting for more candidates
than the voters entitled to 23 writing
or marking by which the voter could be
identified 6 being unmarked or wholly
void for uncertainty 56 and rejected in
part non total rejected ballot papers
were 85 and I do hereby declare that the
said derec twig is duly elected for the
Halton constituency
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you David
first of all kind of problem record my
thanks to Debbie Parr as a return offset
and all these staff who worked on the
election and run the election it's
obviously gotten very very smoothly
throughout and I know a lot of hard work
has been pointing for everyone not least
the cause tonight as well so thank you
very much for all that efforts and
ensuring we had a very straightforward
election I also want to thank my agents
down hill my my campaign team Andrea and
Phil and of course my wife my children
and my wider family for the support that
they gave me as well I'm really pleased
with the results as you can probably
tell it's a tremendous result in terms
of the numbers of people have voted out
and turned labour but we fall about to
say a few more words politically I just
want to say my thoughts tonight are also
with all those who were affected by the
Terrorism that took place in our cities
in Manchester and in London of course
just before the election we had to tear
us a tuck in in Westminster itself and
our my thoughts and prayers are with
them clearly there were many questions
to be asked about security in the coming
weeks and months what's at this point I
just want to make it clear that I do
still think of those people who've been
in some way affected but it's they've
lost loved ones all have been injured or
traumatized by it but it is about our
democracy and despite that we continue
democracy might have its failings
sometimes but there's not a better
system and I think it's absolutely
essential with you defend our democracy
I'd ensure that we continue to have
elections and then I want to follow on
record my thanks as well to the police
and security services for the work they
do it is quite an amazing night here in
Halton that we had such a tremendous
result for the Labour Party and when
I've been doing Arctic talking on the
doorsteps to various people during the
election they've told me that a strong
support for the Labour Party the fact
that the Labour MP working closely with
the Labour Council has delivered and is
delivering things for Halton as we can
see from the Versa gateway right across
down to what's happening at our schools
and in our hospitals and of course
various very sort of things that
happened in within the Halton itself and
that's about working together in party
and that's what I think people
recognized here we've never labour as
never took the vote for granted here
people say oh you is a
labor seeds we have never ever treated
it that way and never will at the
campaign wedding the work was put in by
my campaign and all the labor members
and all the volunteers we put hours and
hours of time in knocking on doors
talking to people and sweets told show
that we do not take it for granted
no we will work hard here to earn the
votes of the people to hold them because
they deserve the very best and that's
what we intend to give them now we don't
know what the results going to be
tonight we've got a very interesting
exit poll and Norman knows whether
that's accurate not at this stage but
clearly masses have moved a great deal
from the start of this election when the
Conservatives call this election and
they called it whether there was no need
for it to be called in the first place
the reason mayor said a few weeks before
there'd be no election and then called
the election for purely party political
gain not for the interests of the
country the Labour Party had already
said that it were voted for article 50
and that we were obviously going down
the road of Breck's if it's about
getting the best deal and I think with
the Tories have been found out too nice
in this in the results you've seen so
far whatever it will be at the end
it's nothing near what they thought it
would get and I think it's gonna be some
very interesting conversations taking
place across the political spectrum not
least in the Conservative Party over the
coming weeks but my priorities will
continue to be what they always have
been and that it's making sure that the
people of Halton have a very strong
voice in Westminster so I'm fighting to
make sure we get the best possible deal
whether it's resources or other things
within wholesome working with the labour
Council to deliver that really education
health transport environment they're key
issues for us and I'll make them a
priority but also security and defence
you're going to be in one of my
priorities which always has beads to
continue tickly what's given what's
taking place in the recent weeks so
we'll continue with those properties
listen to people listen to constituents
and do whatever I can to help people so
I just want to say thank you very much
for the support I received for the
people are holding up our on thanks the
fact that the people have also have
voted with such an overwhelming majority
are with the confidence that they have
and I will repay that and I believe in
the common good I believe in doing the
best I can
I'm making a difference to the people of
Olson and I will continue to do that so
thank you very much for your support
you